and tonight while president biden
lounges on the beach in keough and south
carolina we're now tracking multiple
breaking stories tonight including new
developments from the shooting death
potentially caused by alec baldwin we
have more hypocrisy on climate change
this time with private jet hollywood
hypocrite leonardo dicaprio where do you
hear what he did and a shocking report
from minnesota where one teachers union
would decide to lay people off based on
their race regardless of their seniority
we'll tell you that story and later
we'll show you how one brave good
samaritan took matters into his own
hands by chasing down a violent robbery
suspect but first tonight tensions
remain very high only one week after the
fbi's raid on the 45th president's home
mar-a-lago now this unprecedented search
and seizure has further eroded sadly
many americans trust in the fbi and the
doj and is now causing the outrage all
across the country make no mistake the
fbi has earned their shattered
reputation and tonight we're going to
break down very specifically why
conservatives and trump supporters and
many republicans no longer trust what
should have been and should be and can
be and once was the premier law
enforcement agency in the entire world
let me be clear this is very important
criticizing and questioning the
atrocious behavior
of the upper echelon of the fbi
is not in any way shape manner or form a
call to violence just today fox news is
learning that former president trump
directed his team to reach out to the
department of justice the message donald
trump will do whatever he can to help
our country because quote the
temperature has to be brought down now
president trump is right on this program
we totally condemn all threats against
the fbi and every other member of law
enforcement if you watch this show we
are consistent no doubt there are cops
that are bad apples we saw that in the
george floyd case they commit crimes
they abuse their power and target their
political enemies those people must all
be held accountable in a court of law
and that would also apply to bad apples
in the fbi now sadly that almost never
happens if donald trump or a trump
supporter is the target of the abuse for
example take a look at former fbi
official peter strzok think deeply about
this go back to august 8 2016. strzok's
girlfriend top fbi lawyer lisa page
absolutely terrified at the prospect of
a trump presidency she texts peter
strzok uh her lover her colleague quote
trump's not ever going to become
president right right struck response
he's not
we'll
stop it he said that as that he said all
of that is a top fbi official one that
worked directly for the top leadership
in the fbi then a week later strzok
texted quote i want to believe that the
path that you threw out for
consideration in andy assumably andrew
mccabe's office that there's no way he
gets elected but i'm afraid we can't
take that risk
it's like an insurance policy in the
unlikely event you die before 40.
so a top fbi agent with an insurance
policy
will stop it to thwart the will of the
american people and ensure that one
candidate can never win a free or fair
election in america by the way where's
that january 6 committee looking into
this issue now of course the insurance
policy was none other than the russia
collusion hoax peter strzok became the
lead investigator into this bogus
conspiracy theory his bias was clear it
was obvious his mission was political
and yet struck he never ever faced legal
consequences it's why i often say we
don't have equal justice or equal
application of our laws in america any
longer that is a sad thing to say but
sadly it's true strzok ends up with a
book deal his anti-trump fbi girlfriend
got hired by msdnc strzok himself has
received numerous invitations to appear
all over cable news including this
morning he was on with liberal morning
joe our old friend take a look
it's not that the fbi is targeting any
one side or the other what you see is
the fbi going out on a day-in day-out
basis objectively investigating
allegations of law
the guy that said we'll stop it we'll
stop it the fbi will stop it uh and if
your plan doesn't work we've got an
insurance policy no way he's going to
win the lack of self-awareness there it
should seem shocking to everybody but
keep in mind neither strzok nor his
superiors at the fbi
none of them have ever been held
accountable for example peter strzok's
boss andrew mccabe also was very open
about his hatred for donald trump mccabe
along with jim comey we know he hates
trump and yates sally yates rod
rosenstein they all signed off on either
the fisa warrant or the three subsequent
renewal warrants in doing so all of them
lied on an application that at the top
of the application says verified that
they verified the information we now
know
none of it was true all of the
information that they used was
unverifiable because it's all been
debunked they committed fraud against a
court of law no equal justice or
application of our laws nobody was held
accountable the evidence they used was
neither true nor was it verified or
verifiable the bulk of the supporting
material
in each of those fisa applications was
that woman hillary rodham clinton's
dirty russian misinformation dossier
that she paid for
they were warned that the dossier was
filled with salacious campaign op
research including russian
disinformation and it was not to be
trusted they were they were warned by
even bruce ohr in august of 2016. don't
use it and yet they used it anyway and
they swore in a court of law that it was
verified because as mccabe once admitted
they didn't have that dossier they
weren't going to get that visa
application approved and they were
desperate to spy on the trump campaign
at that particular time and the trump
transition team and later the trump
white house no one was ever charged with
lying to the fisa court even after they
all admitted oh you know um well i i
guess if i had to do it all over again i
wouldn't do it and if i knew now what i
should have known then take a look
if you knew then what you know now would
you have signed the warrant application
in june of 2017 against carter page
uh no sir okay if you knew then what you
know now would you have signed the
warrant application
no i would not i believe you didn't know
that what you signed was wrong the
question is if you had known you
wouldn't assign it is that correct
no if i had known that it contained
incorrect information i certainly
wouldn't have signed knowing then what
you know now about all the things that
we've come to find
would you have still signed the warrant
application against carter page in
october january and april
no i would want a much more complete
understanding of what we wrote thank you
very much
so they're all admitting that they set
they signed a document that has verified
the word verified at the top
was not verifiable not one person held
accountable for what is corruption and
an egregious abuse of power especially
not the patron saint of the fbi jim
comey himself after getting fired by the
former president comey of course leaked
privilege material to the new york times
through a friend in order to smear
donald trump of course comey's home was
never raided by the fbi by the way
neither was hillary clinton's house in
chappaqua and she grossly mishandled
classified information then attempted to
cover her tracks she deleted 33 000
emails nobody had ever heard a bleach
bit before that we all know what it is
now comey gave her a free pass then even
though he found evidence of serious
crimes including that the fact that her
servers were hacked by foreign entities
that put our country at risk no we're
not going to charge hillary take a look
secretary clinton's use of a personal
email domain was both known by a large
number of people and readily apparent
she also used her personal email
extensively while outside the united
states including
sending and receiving work-related
emails in the territory of sophisticated
adversaries
given that combination of factors we
assess it is possible that hostile
actors gained access to secretary
clinton's personal email account
hostile regimes had access to top secret
classified information she allowed that
to happen and she was not held
accountable so let's be very clear here
if you're hillary clinton and put your
country at risk you're going to get a
free pass if you're jim comey you leak
confidential government material through
a friend to the medium mob you get a
free pass if you're a high-ranking
trump-hating bureaucrat who lies to a
fisa court you'll also get a free pass
if you're a top fbi investigator who
vows to use his power to stop a free and
fair election
we'll stop it we've got an insurance
policy you'll get a pass also if you're
hunter biden you can sell access to the
federal government to china to russia to
ukraine and even implicate your own
father the big guy over and over again
and you're going to get a pass no early
morning rate on hunter biden or joe
biden that will probably never happen
despite the prima facie case against him
and if you're joe biden you can leverage
one billion taxpayer dollars get a
ukrainian prosecutor fired who was
investigating your crack addicted son
who was making millions of dollars and
he had no experience with ukraine oil
energy gas whatsoever nothing's going to
happen on the other hand if you are a
conservative watch out if you're roger
stone you commit a process crime you
lied to congress you're going to get a
massive pre-dawn raid guns drawn frogmen
in the water complete with fake news cnn
cameras tipped off to be there at 5 45
in the morning and film it all if you
paul manafort and you commit a fairer
violation or a tax violation again
hardly crimes that are dangerous to
society another massive pre-dawn raid
guns pointed at your face your wife's
face followed by months of solitary
confinement to break you by the way his
new book out you should read it it's
called political prisoner it's out by
the way tomorrow paul manafort will be
on the show tomorrow you need to read
that book if you peter navarro you get
charged with a misdemeanor you get
shackled at the airport for a
misdemeanor handcuffed thrown in jail
the same cell that john hinckley was
thrown in the guy that tried to
assassinate ronald reagan now even the
45th president of the united states he
has been targeted by an early morning
raid and not only did agents show up in
force guns drawn
to the former president's home
but they also demanded that the security
cameras be turned off and they even
blocked the president's attorneys from
observing the search now why would they
do that how many years have we fought
for body cams on police to keep
everybody honest why wouldn't you want
the surveillance cameras kept on
anything you're hiding now tonight
congress has a duty to hold the fbi and
the department of justice those people
at the top levels accountable instead
top democrats in the majority are acting
like cheerleaders just listen to the
congenital liar himself adam schiff
if the trump people
represented that they provided all the
classified or national security
information and didn't
that's a serious problem and i could
tell you anyone in the intelligence
community that had
documents like that marked top secret
sci
in their residence after authorities
went to them um you know they would be
under serious investigation
you mean like hillary oh that's right
she's a democrat why talk about her when
it comes to donald trump or trump
associates it's always guilty until
proven innocent and that congenital liar
by the way doesn't care about evidence
or truth he just wants to smear slander
besmirch donald trump every single
moment of every day now of course for
years the media mob has always been more
than happy to give that liar a platform
to spew even more lies here's a quick
reminder
donald trump is someone who has shown
when he's not held accountable he goes
on to commit worse and worse abuses of
power
so i
agree with judge carter in california i
think there was evidence that the former
president engaged in
multiple
violations of the law
and that should be investigated we have
the president of the united states
engaged in a shakedown of a foreign
president
a president of the united states even as
he is withholding vital military support
to an ally
asking a favor of that ally to
investigate his opponent i've been very
clear over the last year a year and a
half that there is ample evidence of
collusion in plain sight i can certainly
say with confidence that there is
significant evidence of
collusion between the campaign and
russia there is already in my view ample
evidence in the public domain on the
issue of collusion
if you're willing to see it
adam schiff is a dishonest corrupt
congenital liar political hack but sadly
many leaders in the fbi are just
mirroring the kind of destructive
unethical behavior as him let me be
unequivocal in my statement we don't
support violence as conservatives we
believe in law enforcement law and order
and safety and security and we believe
all law enforcement needs to be
protected we just want you to stop
giving us reasons not to trust you
you're earning distrust by allowing all
of these people that are corrupt and
have abused power to get away with it
the director ray clean up this mess stop
treating conservatives one way democrats
another way that would be a great first
step and then get rid of the bad apples
at the top of your organization now
punish the people that are corrupt
punish the people that abuse their power
because it's tarnishing the reputation
of the 95 percent of good agents that
serve this country with honor and
distinction and it's unfortunate that
most of us who are the most inclined to
revere law enforcement now have a deep
distrust because of the actions of a few
and you haven't cleaned it up hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else